this is the theme the danger this is the
thesis the bismillah al hamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be unto you thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Dean show this week we have with us
again dr. Haughton who is a PhD who is
the doctor who's a shake who's an MD
pediatrician who deals with kids and we
covered a show with him we did a part 12
this we're doing the sequel now you can
go to his section to read a little bit
more about him he's given us some advice
on the million-dollar question how to
make sure your kids don't go astray
they've been given to you pure an
original good goodness not original sin
that child is born in a state of purity
how do you keep them away from all the
bad things evil things that are out
there it starts at an early age and
these are the questions that we're going
to be picking his brain about when we
come back here on the Dean show will be
right back
hey this is the thing the biju this is
the things is the danger this is the
venue this is the thing is just Athene
jus this is the Salam alaikum peace walk
a few my likeness alarm from one thank
you very much for finding time to be
with us here on the Dean show thank you
for inviting you in place to be here now
people go to your section they can read
about you you are also i didn't mention
the the Dean right of the sharia academy
yes look you see the facial expression i
just made because you know what there's
a lot of not yet muslims a muslim is one
who's chosen you know Jesus obviously
was a Muslim Moses was a Muslim there's
some people like is this guy crazy
Muslim is obviously one who surrendered
his will to the will of the Creator but
there's some people when they hear
Sharia and they say we don't want no
Surya over here but what is you know
they feel like this is the boogeyman is
coming to get us before we go on to our
topic what is Sharia mean Sharia is the
way to survival the way to success
realize the past that God had shown us
to to our prosperity in this life and
the one to come sorry I used to mean in
arabic the past water bodies and in
Islam the way that Allah had shown us is
called Sharia because as much as weather
is important and essential for your
physical will being the way of God is
essential for your spiritual well-being
and we're not only mattered we are a
mixture of matter and something else
which is the spiritual aspect of human
see that people or some people neglect
or or wish to forget about one more one
more this just briefs not on top of it
but just just so someone's heart can be
rest assured they heard Muslim we define
Islam and Muslims surrendering to one
God the God of Abraham Moses Jesus peace
be upon all and the last and final
messenger problem Hamid peace be upon
them so they can rest assured now we
define what Sharia is it's not the
boogeyman it's a way from the create or
for success and now about terrorism
Islam and terrorism what you guys say
about this when it's all done who they
are if you say Islam they say tear they
say you know what all all terror is not
Muslim but all Muslims seem to be doing
terrorism what do we got to say about
this well it is absolutely not true I
mean if you know a simple study of the
history will show that this is
completely false and war has been
started by various people at various
times for various reasons Islam the
Prophet of Islam prophet muhammad
sallallahu sunlon says to us do not wish
to confront your enemies but if you do
be patient so war is not the default or
is to be avoided or may be necessary at
some times because of the cause of god
which is the cause of justice and
fairness and to deliver the oppressed
from their oppression and and so on and
so forth and if you look at the earlier
muslims when they engaged in war it was
all about this it was not all of it was
never about any feelings of supremacy
ethnic or otherwise because i slam in
you know if you look at the history for
instance the d turks were not Arabs the
Turks are not Arabs Turks were not
Muslims and for very Europeans
particularly they remembered Turkish a
conquest and this and that well the
Turks were not Muslim but
and when they conquer the Muslim land
Islam compared their hearts so they
became Muslims and it was never a matter
of you know ethnic supremacy the this
struggle against the evil as a struggle
that begins from within the first one
that you need to struggle against the is
yourself but is not limited to that it
is not limited struggling against
yourself Islam also teaches us that you
want to struggle against the evil within
and without outside as well so the to
struggle against the evil does not mean
does not necessarily mean war does not
necessarily mean violence so the
struggle against the evil is to take
whole it is to try all other
alternatives first before the surgical
alternative that is to be avoided that
is to be deferred that no one wishes for
and the way of the Prophet peace be upon
him is is actually a testimonial on all
of those facts and the entire history at
estadisticas just this to this very fact
after this that in Islam war has ethics
that are matchless before you know the
Geneva Convention and before everything
the warrior 6 in Islam the command of
the Prophet peace be upon him to not
kill a child an elderly person a woman
and even the Prophet peace be upon him
have the ads in a Cell narration to not
kill a thief a thief means the
non-combatants member of the army so
that will apply to physicians and you
know journalism and so on and so forth
so it goes as you know as far as this
you know the promises are meant as far
in preceding those Geneva Conventions
the instructors that not only that we do
not get women and children elderly but
we do not even kill the lankan
members of the army of the of the enemy
if they were not combatant hidden after
this the the Muslims for you no honor
their covenants and they don't do a
treachery and the they don't betray and
they always on a regular covenant so
when Muslims are given security
somewhere they do not betray the
covenant with those who gave them that
security so now people are getting a
different picture this is not our topic
we just wanted to not yet Muslims to get
a better understanding so now they can
be open for the advice that we give so
tell us we talked about children and
this is our future the future umma is
those kids coming up and in the previous
show you can go back to the Dean show
calm and you can see part one that we
did with dr. Haughton shift about the
million-dollar question how to raise the
children and prevent them from going
astray we talked about the early years
mercy making sure that children aren't
in pain that they're being fed that all
their needs are being met and now we
went from two and up talking about the
timeout method and some practical
examples so when we come back we're
going to continue this here on the Dean
show don't go nowhere this is I don't
say to people i used to be a Christian I
still carry the values and principles of
loving Jesus Christ and perhaps maybe
more than evil comes as Christians so I
think I got the best out of Christianity
by becoming mostly
so many other things that you can enjoy
without drinking a sip of alcohol this
is the same thing it's not an obstacle
it's not something to cause people to
get completely desperate and start
talking living their lives no it should
be a motivation it's only one life that
you're going to be living so you better
do it for the last channel matata I am
not afraid to stand alone if allies by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone if allies
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Eliza I am Not Afraid
back here with Cher dr. Hutton so tell
us now we left off from the last show at
the age now we're about somewhere you
know going up three where so we went
from the time our method how to
discipline them before we go on to seven
what you just said just just a few more
example so is it safe to say that the
child you can't just let him be doing
whatever he wants there's got to be some
guidelines right and you we gave some
practical example to time out method and
how you talk to them we want to also ask
you now and if you can library on what I
just said about foul language from the
parents cursing bad behavior do the
children pick up on all these things and
then can this be counter effective if
you're not getting yourself together but
you expect a child now to be mr. prince
and princess well first of all you know
cursing and calling people bad names as
certainly counter this num the Prophet
peace be upon him says ladies lace and
Muslim disability or Allah what a fire
shall be a Muslim is not one who curses
is not one who calls names and is not
one who is obscene that's our teachings
that is what the Prophet said the Muslim
can not be they cannot the tongue you
used to praise the crater you can't
curse with that time absolutely oh
absolutely and again these are going
back to the issue of contradiction
that's the worst thing that's worst
quality the person has is contradiction
you know the worst kind of people that
are mentioned in the Quran are the
hypocrites and the hypocrites their
problem is contradiction you know
actions and sayings the end they would
what is inside then what is outside the
exterior and the interior once you have
contradictions then the you really
compromise your integrity you really
compromise your credibility on the side
of your child and keep in mind kids are
not done yeah they actually can can read
through the lines and they can actually
see deep into you
and they can actually pick up the clues
that you're really not consistent
consistent you gotta be consistent they
need to be consistent yeah and what up
what about now the because it starts off
early too if you're watching daytime
nighttime drama on the TV this boob tube
that's out there what do you got to say
about this that is also be not
consistent in your raising of a child
because you know when people talk about
this is okay for adults and this is not
okay for our children I think that
message is really not making a lot of
sense to the children so you gotta be 18
to you know like here we in America I
don't think that for Muslims that issue
is such a prevalent problem but you know
you can't buy alcohol and tell you this
and you can't watch this Anthony or that
and you can gamble until you're like the
artist many years old hehe 13-unit is it
but yeah so the job would say you know
so so what happened to me overnight you
know like yesterday it was Quran and
today it's Haddad or yesterday's / is
impermissible today it's permissible
what nothing you happen to be avail
existing absolutely so we Muslims should
not be doing this you know you should
not be telling them that there is this
is good for adults not good for kids or
this it's okay for me to do that it's
okay for me to to be obscene it's okay
for me to call names or curse it's good
to me for me to be vulgar to be rougher
to be this or that but it's not okay for
you why I mean if it is ok it's ok for
both of us and if it is not okay it's
not okay for both of us so that is one
thing that people really need to
understand in order for them to be
effective preachers and reaching out to
their kids are these kids picking up if
you if you're having like this music
playing on the TV you know that the
different Jerry Springer shows martel
Willie all the crazy things that are on
the TV and now just to get the kids in
front of TV and now you got some peace
you feel like you know what he's quiet
now just let them be but is this some
programming going on profanity
promiscuity and now years past is just
going to have an influence should this
be in the Muslims house or away from the
Muslims house that's an excellent point
because bye-bye h2 you can make phrases
and sentences and by h5 you would have
actually developed the majority of your
language yeah so between two to five in
terms of language development that area
is very very sensitive so see what it is
that you are because there is input here
the input is coming from the parents
coming from the TV it's and don't expect
that the input would be one thing and
the output will be a different thing you
know the input every input into the
child will be a you know manifested by
little child thereafter so if the child
is is using profanity URI is his
language is foul when her language is
fouled then you want to ask yourself
where did this come from you know it
came from what I allowed the child to be
exposed to and what you and part of that
is you know my own language so you have
to be careful with your own language if
you teach the child this early on words
like inshallah God willing and hundred
Allah praise be to Allah and they go
into his language the you know and the
develop with him they will not only be
part of the language but they also be
part of the makeup the emotional and
psychological makeup of the child the
word condola has great power praise be
to Allah and if your child sees that you
say and hunted Allah even when you're in
pain even when you have suffered some
loss that that's a great lesson without
giving any lectures without having any
microphone and given any lectures it's a
great lesson as the child will then
understand that you know we can even be
content even during hard times and we
recognize or less bounties and favours
on us because they're there are
unlimited the you know he can't count
so even if I lost this particular thing
that you know that matters to me there
is so much that I have so now with the
TV what I like to do now I mean if we do
watch something is a good too I like
hooda TV in peace TV there's some
Islamic channels out there is this okay
now if the children along with possibly
what can you start reading to them at a
young age you know so what are the
things that you could implement as far
as like knowledge going on from two
three four five and up before they go to
or because I guess the first school is
the home school you know so before they
do anything else making sure like the
bad things aren't coming in so what can
you cut off and then to replace it what
can you replace it with good things I
think that there should be some
controlled exposure I think that there
should be exposure to sort of like you
give them samples of of life outside but
nothing bad but again at the same time a
hood a TV PCV the beach Oh etc all of
that is great and good but there could
be also some programs on discovery
channel for instance that you can deem
appropriate I think that you need to
pre-screen rescreening is very important
I think yeah because you do not want
your child to be exposed to something
completely you know because you got also
i'll try and the virtual you got thongs
i mean this is the real world you know
it's actually it's like a soft porn on
just the you know average commercials
that there is there is too much
exploitation of whether women yeah
choose which is quiet that's the real
subjugation of women it should be it
yeah it should be it would be quite
hurtful to the german that they're being
used you know for attraction to grab
attention yeah what the female body is
being used as a commodity to grab
people's attention even if you're
advertising for a tractor what does the
tractor have to do with a beautiful
woman yeah but it's just like if trying
to grab people's attention and I don't
want my child to be explore
to this and I don't want this the this
emphasis on you know over emphasis on
sex to be deliver to my child this early
on so that's the pre-screening will come
back here in a disha with some more
after this break don't go nowhere you
will not kill a woman do not kill a
child do not you know going to different
religious leaders Buddhism in Division
forms of Christianity I even ran into
people from the nation of the slop
feeling very mad do not feel an animal
you will not cut a tree down do not
commute the water do not burn their
homes
back here with dr. Haughton PhD MD given
us some great advice here on the Dean
show and we only have a few more minutes
so we want to again we're going to have
to have you back and just continue this
series continues our series God willing
so tell us more a few more important
points that the parents should know
about and then we'll go from there on
how they could you've read you've
written some books and some articles
where do you can continue on this is
such a vast topic well one of the points
that they want to touch upon is that the
issue of encouragement and encouragement
is is very important and particularly
from age six and seven this issue or
this this particular stage of the
child's life is called the stage of
inferiority versus industry and the the
key to this stage as encouragement use
less discouragement and more
encouragement so use more positive
reinforcement and less negative even for
example please I'll give you an example
how you know and in fact is only one of
the tab a in which are the
second-generation Muslims said two young
boys do not do not think little of
yourselves do not belittle yourselves
Omar even a laptop that is Omer moffat
odd use the inviting people to consult
them on great matters to follow the
sharpness of their minds or it is
seeking the sharpness of their thinking
process because adults could be
multifaceted yes but that could
overwhelm your thinking so he wants to
see the unidimensional thinking and the
children have the uni-dimensional
thinking so when armor invites you
that's the the leader of the Muslims he
used elite well you know more than 20 of
the contemporary countries so when the
leader of more than 20 of the
contemporary countries brings the
children over and consult them on
various matters some of them are
important you can imagine how
they were builders of character they
were builders of great leaders and that
is what the perfect peace be upon him
dead the Prophet hired October glass
seed to be his vice roi on Mecca when he
was less than 20 mojada manageable was
less than 20 when he sent him as an
ambassador to a Yemeni and the love now
advance was only 10 when the Prophet
peace be upon him died and a blog nezu
layer was was about to say to in the
prophet peace be aware they work you
know contemporaries or the you know
there are equal in age peers of the
lovin is available on our best see how
much they benefited from their company
the companionship of the Prophet peace
be upon him because he and he welcomed
them he was warm to them he would shake
hands with with children in the street
to give them self confidence so that it
encourage them and give a give them self
confidence so that become the leaders of
tomorrow and that's what we feel
oftentimes to do few more ensure i'm
going to ask you just some questions and
you tell me good or bad and just
elaborate for a moment before we cut out
always screaming at the children when
they do something wrong good or bad you
know it's bad it is bad it was it is
basically ineffective you know yeah well
you need to diversify your response to
be effective because otherwise the kids
will get immunogen start screaming you
develop humanity like you develop unity
bugs even better community to behavior
also so when someone has a certain
behavior you develop immunity to that
behavior even between the spouses and
people need to you know understand that
this is quite an effective way of a
preaching public school good event ah if
there are alternatives been bad okay
I've heard it being compared to
spiritual suicide I heard actually this
is a check of the lesson from a Diana
Institute he was calling it a man
warfare Oh
so it was a void the public good yeah if
there are alternatives yeah yes if there
are alternatives and there are
alternatives the community is neat
Muslim communities need to come up with
more and more alternatives not limited
to Islamic schools but also tutoring in
the Messiah in them and the message ads
for homeschooled kids if we do this we
can help a lot of parents who can't do
it alone to do it with a little bit of
help yeah last closing comments and
suggestions wrapping it up for those
since your parents who want the best for
themselves and their family what
encouragement and advice you give much
here I think you always start from and
go back to the the two conditions of the
validity of anything we do in Islam
which is sincerely and correctness and
insincerity is defined defined by
complete devotion to a line that which
you do you have to make sure that you
are actually serving his interest not
your limited narrow personal interest
and correctness is by following the path
of the Prophet peace be upon him walk
behind them he's leading you to the
right way and on the right way to the
right and then if you start to walk away
here there you can be he can fall into
traps of the Satan's walk right behind
him you will get to where you believe he
will get to and as a Muslim if you
believe that he's giving to paradise
what Craig behind them he'll lead you
there that make sense is simple and just
in the last few seconds where can people
go to continue their education and reach
more of your work in your material how
they can go to mg online that work am j
a online org one word you can also go to
sharia academy com imes online as the
assembly muslim jurists in America entry
Academy is a higher learning institution
just Oklahoma God Almighty Allah reward
you for being much thank you thank you
very much
Thanks thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean show it
starts with wanting the treasures out
there but do you want it God Almighty
Allah has sent us the guidance through
the last and final message the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him and not much
to add after the Sheikh has told us that
we need to stick to the verbatim word of
God the Quran and follow me behind the
one that's leading us to Jenna he's the
way the truth from the light the problem
Mohamed last and final messenger just
the same way that you would have to not
bypass the teachings of Jesus and Moses
Abraham you had to teach you had to
follow the teachers not worship them
they weren't God's demigods they didn't
call you to worship themselves but they
called you to follow them because they
were the ones who are teaching us how to
get to paradise how to be successful not
only in this life but also in the
hereafter and we have the guidance from
the last and final message sent to
mankind a problem how much peace be upon
them so let's be successful let's have
success in this life and the next until
next time peace be unto you
you